Dreamflow just got an update. So let me
show you some of the features. The first
one is Superbase edge functions. So now
you can write and deploy Superbase edge
functions right from Dreamflow. So let
me show you how this works. So I've
already got a Superbase project
connected here. And if I scroll down,
you can see I've got this edge functions
section. So I can come in and create an
edge function. And it's going to pop me
over to the agent because the agent has
these capabilities. And so it says,
"Please generate a superbase edge
function that is a proxy service for
open AI." Okay, great. So our agent has
written these Typescript files. If you
want to go see them, you can just click
into this view code right here and it'll
open up the actual function. And you can
see another great feature that we've
released is secrets. So the agent
recognized that we need some secure
secrets here like our open AI key
allowed origins and base URL. So it's
propagated this secrets feature right
here. So if I come in here and edit
this, let's put in our value and accept
it. Now that's deployed in Superbase.
Now our function isn't deployed yet. For
safety and security reasons, the agent
won't deploy these for you so that you
can review the code before you deploy.
Now, if you have multiple edge functions
here, you can deploy them individually
using this button right here, or deploy
all of them right here. Awesome. And now
that's deployed. And because your agent
knows about this, it'll be able to
design the architecture of your app
around these services that you've set
up. Next, we've increased the character
input max length to your agent. So,
previously it was at 10,000 characters.
Now, it's 50,000. This means that if
you've got a larger PRD or spec document
that you want to pass to your agent or
maybe pass some documentation for a
library that you're using, you're able
to add much greater context. So there's
this new package swift animations that I
wanted to use. But because it's a new
package, the agent had trouble
integrating it into my app. So instead,
I use this service get ingest to grab
the documentation. So then my agent was
better able to understand the API and
integrate it into my project. Finally,
the speed of the agent has drastically
improved. So, you should see much faster
performance with the same quality out of
the agent in Dreamflow. Those are the
updates this week. Let us know if you
have any questions and we'll see you in
the next video.